[music playing]
The Chiles-Witted sighting
takes place July 24, 1948,
during a red-eye flight
actually from Houston to Atlanta
on a DC3 passenger plane.
The pilots of this
aircraft were Clarence
Chiles and Charles Witted.
These are both
experienced pilots.
And what they saw
was a very rapid
flight of an object
that flew apparently
close to the airliner.
RICHARD DOLAN: I mean, you're
talking maybe 100 feet,
maybe 200 feet away.
In the air at that altitude,
that's really close and enough
to frighten any sane,
rational pilot as to wondering
what this thing was.
It happened very quickly.
One of the pilots thought that
he saw illuminated windows
across the object.
RICHARD DOLAN: It's interesting
that both of these pilots
drew what they saw,
and what you find
is they are remarkably similar.
They both show this elongated
object, like a rocket
or like a missile, except
it's got a little kind
of a tail thing that they
depict and those layers
of windows, which are
very, very distinctive.
And was followed
by a trail, which
led to the official explanation
that this might be a meteor.
The problem with the explanation
is that they described
the object as turning up and
flying up into the clouds
and up into the sky.
Meteors don't do that, and
balloons don't do that, either.
So we can no go
back and say the Air
Force explanation for that
particular case in 1948
is a wrong one.
[music playing]